hi everyone this is Professor andas
science and today we will derive the
energy gigen values of a general
two-state Quantum system in another one
of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics many important Quantum systems
are described by two dimensional State
spaces a very famous example is the
electron which is a spin one half
particle and another example is a cubit
which is the building block of a quantum
computer in this video we're going to
calculate the energy I values of a
general two-state Quantum system which
amounts to diagonalizing a 2x2 matrix
there is also a companion video where we
calculate the corresponding IG States so
make sure that you check us out so let's
go let's set up the basics of a
two-state Quantum system we consider a
general hamiltonian H which can be
expressed as a 2x2 matrix like
this remember that the hamiltonian is a
h Mission operator so H is equal to H
dagger we find in the video on the 2x2
matrix space that for a 2x2 matrix to
represent a hom Mission operator we must
have that the diagonal elements h11 and
H22 are real numbers and the of diagonal
elements are the complex conjugates of
each
other the aim of today's video is to
find the iig values of a general
hamiltonian of a two-state Quantum
system and that means that we will be
interested in solving this igen value
equation where as usual these are the
igen values and these are the igen
stakes to State Quantum systems play a
key role in many areas of quantum
mechanics from the spin angular momentum
of spin one half particles to the cubits
of quantum computers and that means that
what we will learn today will will find
applications in many areas of physics
and you can find examples in the videos
that we've linked
below whenever we want to find the igen
values and IG states of an operator or
Matrix we need to consider the
corresponding characteristic equation
which in our case is given by the
determinant of this expression set to
zero if we consider the argument of the
determinant we can explicitly write out
the hamiltonian Matrix minus Lambda time
the identity Matrix if we evaluate this
expression we end up with h11 minus
Lambda h12
h21 and H22 minus
Lambda this means we need the
determinant of this
expression to be equal to zero the
determinant of a 2x2 matrix is simply
the product of the diagonal terms
minus the product of the off diagonal
terms and we need to set this to
zero let's make some rum and let's copy
down the polinomial equation we need to
solve to determine the IG values we can
multiply out the first term here to
obtain Lambda s minus Lambda * h11 +
H22 plus h11 *
H22 we then add the second term here
which we simply copy and set this all to
zero this is a second order polinomial
equation of this general form where in
our case the unknown X is given by the I
value
Lambda you probably first learned the
solution to these quadratic equations in
secondary school and it is given by this
expression
here this result shows that as expected
a second second order polinomial
equation has two solutions given by the
plus and the minus signs
here using this General solution for our
expression we get that Lambda is equal
to 12 * h11 + H22 + - 12 time theare <
TK of h11 + H22
2- 4 * h11 * H22 - h12 *
821 let's make some room again and let's
copy down the expression that we got for
the I
values we can further simplify the
argument of the square root if we start
with this Square here we can expand it
out into the usual three
terms we then copy the remaining terms
here and I'm going to slightly rewrite
them for
convenience we next need to note two
facts first we can combine these two
terms to get minus 2 * h11
H22 and we can then combine all of these
into h11 - H2 2^
2 second as h12 and ht1 are each other's
complex conjugates we can write this
term as the absolute value of h12 all
squared and now putting everything
together we find that the I values
Lambda of a general 2x2 hamiltonian are
given by 12 * h11 + H22 + - 12 * the <
TK of h11 - H22
2+ 4 * the absolute value of h12 all
squared
and this it whenever we have a two-state
Quantum system we can find its IG values
by evaluating this expression in terms
of the corresponding Matrix
elements as a sanity check remember that
the igen values of a her Mission
operator are real numbers and you should
convince yourself that this expression
does indeed lead to real I
values let's briefly discuss notation to
make it more consistent with what you
will often encounter when you work with
two-state Quantum
systems so far we've been labeling the
igen values of the hamiltonian with the
generic label Lambda here to make it
clearer that the hamiltonian is the
operator associated with the total
energy of the system it is very common
practice to replace Lambda with E and
additionally as for a two-state Quantum
system we only have two possible I
values it is also very common practice
to distinguish them with a plus minus
sub index in this notation the e+ I
value is given by the expression that
has the plus sign before the square
root and the E minus I value is given by
the expression that has the minus sign
before the square
root to be consistent with this notation
we can also update the corresponding I
States up here and replace S with s plus
minus with this notation the igen value
equation of the hamiltonian of a
two-state Quantum system takes this
form this notation makes it very clear
that the energy spectrum of a two-state
Quantum system is made of two energy ion
values and these systems are often
called TW level
systems
okay so next we will explore these igen
values in some more depth let's consider
the special case when the two I values
are degenerate and that means uh that e+
is equal to e
minus in this case the argument of the
square root must vanish so let's copy
that condition
down as this first term is non- negative
netive and this second term is also non-
negative then their sum can only be zero
if the first term is exactly equal to
zero and the second term is also exactly
equal to
zero from the first condition we get
that h11 must be equal to
H22 and from the second condition we get
that
h12 must
vanish as h 21 is the complex conjugate
of h12 that means that h21 must also
vanish in this case we can write our I
values as equal to this expression where
the square root term has
vanished in this special case we can
simplify the notation further by
noticing that we can use a single label
for the two degenerate igen values and
we will use e and then using the fact
that a h11 is equal to H22 we can
simplify this expression further and
write it as equal to
h11 so what do these results
mean let's consider the usual two-state
hamiltonian if we have two degenerate
Dion values which we label with the same
letter e then the corresponding
hamiltonian must take this very simple
form we can rewrite this as e * time the
Matrix 1 01 which is basically e * the
2x2 identity
Matrix and so all of this means that a
2x2 hamiltonian H will only have a
degenerate Spectrum if it is
proportional to the identity Matrix and
for any other Matrix the Spectrum will
not be the
generate and another thing to note is
that the proportionality constant
is the value of the degenerate I
value right in principle we're done with
what we wanted to
do however you may remember from the
video on the 2x2 matrix space that we
can write any 2x2 matrix in terms of the
identity Matrix which in this context is
typically labeled as Sigma 0er and the
three po matrices Sigma 1 Sigma
2 and sigma
3 as these four matrices are used very
frequently as a basis we're next going
to derive the igen values of the
hamiltonian of a general two-state
Quantum system using this
basis remember from the video on the 2x2
matrix space that we can write an
arbitrary H Mission operator such as a
hamiltonian in terms of a linear
combination of the identity and po
matrices like this explicitly this
expression takes this
form for a general 2x two complex Matrix
the expansion coefficients D are complex
scalers but in this special case in
which the Matrix is a h Mission Matrix
like the hamiltonian here then the
expansion coefficients D are real
scalers another commonly used notation
when dealing with this form is to define
a vector Sigma which contains the three
POI matrices as elements and a vector D
which contains the expansion
coefficients D1 D2 and D3 as
elements and in this more compact
notation we can rewrite the hamiltonian
operator H as d 0 Sigma 0 plus d do
Sigma
so we now have that a general 2x2
hamiltonian can be explicitly written in
terms of its Matrix elements like this
or it can also be written in terms of
the identity and po matrices like this
and we can also write this last
expression explicitly in terms of Matrix
elements involving the D parameters like
this it is very easy to just just read
off the relation between these two
formulations so if we compare these two
entries we get that h11 is equal to d0 +
D3 comparing these two entries we get
that h12 is equal to D1 minus I
D2 if we now compare these two we get
that h21 is equal to D1 plus iid2 and
finally if we compare these two here we
get that H22 is equal to D 0 minus
D3 in the video on the 2x2 matrix base
we also invert these relations and we
find that d0 is given by this
expression D1 is given by this
expression D2 is given by this
expression and D3 is given by this one
here overall we can use either
formulation for a 2x2 hamiltonian and
then relate them through these
equations we often use the formulation
in terms of the identity and po Maes
because it provides useful physical
insights so I think you will often find
yourself calculating the D parameters
using these equations before launching
into subsequent
calculations for this reason we will
finish the video by recalculating the IG
values of a general 2x2 hamiltonian in
terms of the D parameters
we're going to calculate them by
directly diagonalizing this second form
of the hamiltonian but I encourage you
to try calculating them using the
alternative approach of exploiting these
relations between the H Matrix elements
and the D parameters to convert the igen
values we got earlier into their
expression in terms of the D
parameters great so this this is our new
form for the 2x2 hamiltonian that we
want to
diagonalize we again need to consider
the corresponding characteristic
equation which is again given by this
expression but now when we consider the
argument of the determinant we
explicitly write out the hamiltonian
Matrix in terms of D
parameters minus Lambda time the
identity Matrix evaluating this
expression we end up with d 0 + D3 minus
Lambda
D1 - ID D2 D1 + I
D2 and D 0us D3 minus
Lambda this means that we need the
determinant of this
expression to be equal to
zero remember again that the determinant
of a 2x2 matrix is simply the product of
the diagonal terms which I am reordering
in a convenient way minus the product of
the of diagonal
terms and we need to set this to
zero so let's make some room again and
let's copy down the polinomial equation
that we need to solve to determine the I
values both terms have the form a + b *
a minus B which as you know is equal to
a 2 - b^ 2 using this relation we can
write the first term as d 0us Lambda or
SAR minus D3 2 and the second term as
minus D1 2 minus id2 all s and again all
of this is equal to zero we can simplify
this even further by realizing that this
term reduces 2 + D2 2 so that we can
rewrite this as Lambda - d 0^ 2 - D3 2 -
d D1 2us D2 2 and everything equal to
zero note that I've also reordered the
terms inside this Square for
convenience and we can next write this
as Lambda minus d 0^ 2 on the left hand
side equal to D1 2 + D2 2 + D3 2 on the
right hand
side taking the square root of these
Expressions gives this result
and finally we can write our I values
Lambda as equal to d0 plus minus the
square TK of D1 2 plus D2 2 plus D3 2
and these are our two I values when
written in terms of the D
parameters we should also note that we
can rewrite the I values as equal to d0
plusus the magnitude of the D Vector
remembering that we've defined the
vector d as having these three
components okay so let's summarize our
discussion of a two-state Quantum system
we've been working with the hamiltonian
H and considered its IG value
equation we've then looked at two
options first the hamiltonian can be
explicitly written in terms of its
Matrix elements like this and we found
that in this notation the igen values
are given by this
expression alternatively we can rewrite
the hamiltonian in the bases spanned by
the identity and po matrices where the D
parameters are real
parameters in this form the igen values
are given by this
expression and you can use either form
for the hamiltonian when working with a
two-state system and you'll often find
yourself using both both depending on
the context also note that in today's
video we haven't really said anything
about the igen states up here we
actually have a full companion video
discussing the IG States so I really
encourage you to check it out in the
links
below today we found the IG values of a
general two-state Quantum system and
that means that whenever you find a
two-state Quantum system all you have to
do is to quote the results that we've
obtained today another example
application of these results in includes
the study of the interaction between the
electron Spin and a magnetic field but
there are actually many other examples
and also don't forget to check out the
companion video where we calculate the I
states of a general two-state Quantum
system and as always I hope that you
liked the video and please
subscribe